being a stand-up comedian is one of the
hardest jobs in the entertainment
industry if not the hardest job in the
entertainment industry
and it takes a special skill and a
special talent to be able to do that to
be up there on a stage just you and a
microphone and a stool and be able to be
so open and vulnerable you know you hear
stories comedians are more depressed
they have more substance abuse they have
more of this more of that and you know
they're just a really really troubled
population and I I don't necessarily
think they're more trouble than anybody
else the lifestyle of a stand-up
comedian breeds the depression or it can
exacerbate something that's pre-existing
like a bipolar disorder or substance
abuse because what happens is that they
are out on the road and they are by
themselves and they're traveling
sometimes to these areas that aren't
very popular and aren't very pretty and
working in these dark dank clubs and
then going back to a dark dank hotel
room and it gets very very lonely they
don't have their support system they
don't have much of anything there
they're by themselves so when you're
bored you're gonna find something to
entertain yourself with like alcohol or
drugs and that's that's when the
problems start to persist and then it
goes on and on and on from there until
they get treatment
comedians do see comedy as a sort of
self-treatment a lot of times they think
of it as their therapy the problem is is
that being on stage and performing and
doing your yours standup
it's not therapy it is definitely
therapeutic but it is not therapy there
is that thought that if you are
successful if you make more money if you
are admired if you're recognized out on
the street that all your problems are
going to go away that is not true and
again as we saw with Robin Williams his
problems did not go away your problems
just become different they become
different levels of stress different
levels of depression and it's across the
board if you don't deal with your mental
health it's not going to go away there
is a stigma across the board still with
mental health we think that we can't
solve our own problems and if we go seek
help by talking to a therapist
psychologist psychiatrist any other
mental health worker that there is a
problem with us that that we're crazy or
something like that so comedians I think
will and can be a useful resource in
terms of teaching the world about mental
health issues when you come out publicly
and deal with any sort of issue on a
certain level and talk about it as if it
is just something that is not
stigmatized then we won't look at it as
something that is bad or evil I think
what we need to start doing is really
looking at mental health as any other
medical condition that we all experience
you know we have a pain in our knee a
pain in our back we have diabetes we
have a heart condition we go to a doctor
take medication eat right exercise do
what we need to do follow through with
that and and we start getting better
hopefully well that's the same thing
with mental health